2026년 5월 5일 화요일 미국 증시 유약입니다.
금일 미국 증시는 상승 마감했습니다.
미국과 이란의 휴전이 유지되고 있다는 소식에 전면전 우려가 한층 누그러지면서 주가는 오르고 유가는 떨어졌습니다.
호르무제와 봉쇄 여파로 원유 가격은 여전히 높은 수준에서 거래되지만 브랜트유는 배런랑 110달러 아래에서 마감했습니다.
한편 장마감 후 시간의 거래에서는 AMD가 견주한 실적 전망을 내놓았습니다.
최근 호르무제협에서 새로운 공격이 이어지면서 미국과 이란 양국 간의 휴전 상태는 불안정한 모습을 보이고 있습니다.
다만 미 국방부 장관은 언론 브리핑에서 약 한 달 전 발효된 휴전이 여전히 유지되고 있다고 밝혔습니다.
마르코 루비오 국무장관 역시 호르무제협을 통과하는 선방에 대한 군사 지원은 어디까지나
방어적 작전이라면
미국은 선제 공격을 받았을 때에 한해 대응 사격에 나설 것이라고 강조했습니다.
S&P500 지수는 0.8% 상승하며 신고가를 경신했습니다.
이날 시장의 랠리는 반도체 및 메모리 관련 주가 주도했습니다.
마이크론과 샌디스크, 인텔이 일제히 강세를 보인 가운데 특히 인텔의 주가는 13%나 폭등했습니다.
애플이 미국 내 자사 기기용 핵심 프로세서 생산을 위해 인텔 및 삼성전자와 파운드리 활용을 위해
인텔 및 삼성전자와 파운드리 활용을 위해 인텔 및 삼성전자와 파운드리 활용을 위해
초기 논의를 진행 중이라는 소식이 강력한 호재로 작용했습니다.
여기에 대만 메모리 반도체 기업인 나냐테크놀로지가 4월 매출이 전년 동기 대비 717% 폭등했다고 발표한 점도 섹터의 투자 심리를 크게 끌어올렸습니다.
반면 팔런티의 경우 1분기 실적이 예상치를 상회하고 연간 실적 전망까지 상향 조정했음에도 불구하고 주가는 오히려 7% 가까이 급락했습니다.
그러나 전기 기업의 시장은 대만 메모리 반도체 기업인 나냐테크놀로지가 4월 매출이 전년 동기 대비 717% 폭등했다고 발표한 점도 섹터의 투자 심리를 크게 끌어올렸습니다.
전반적인 어닝 시즌은 긍정적입니다.
팩트셋에 따르면 지금까지 실제 발표한 S&P500 기업의 약 85%가 시장 예상치를 상회한 것으로 집계되었습니다.
경제지표 측면에서는 3월 구인 건수는 거의 변동이 없었던 반면 채용은 반등했습니다.
4월 서비스업 확장세는 신규 주문 증가율 둔화 속에 다소 진정된 모습을 보였습니다.
에드워드 존스의 브룩 와이머는
이란과의 긴장이 더 이상 고조되지 않고 있다는 점이
시장의 투자 심리를 뒷받침하고 있다.
LSEG의 화진더 딜러는
S&P500 기업들은 1분기에 전년 동기 대비 28%의 총 이익 성장률을 기록할 것으로 예상되며
이는 2021년 이후 가장 강력한 분기 이익 성장세이다.
US Bank of West Management의 톰 헤일리는
시장은 펀더멘털을 따라가고 있다.
실적이 상당히 강하게 나오고 있으며
이런 흐름이 올해 남은 기간에도 이어질 것이라는 기대가 있다.
라고 전하였습니다.
2026년 5월 6일 수요일 주요 일정 살펴보겠습니다.
경제지표는 22시 15분 미국 4월 ADP 비농업 취업자 수
22시 30분 미국 미 재무부 QRA 발표
22시 30분 연준 무살렘 총재
23시 30분 미국 EIA 원유 재고
02시 연준 굴수비 총재가 예정되어 있습니다.